rumor is Jordan Peele wants to direct a
live-action gargoyles movie like why
hasn't that been greenlit like right now
doesn't really have anything to do with
us I'm just saying it's a good question
to ask why not so us is the new movie
written and directed by Jordan Peele
which can we just address the fact and
appreciate the fact that we're there now
we're at the point where it's like oh
the new Jordan Peele movie most
directors it takes a couple movies to
get there took Jordan Peele one took him
get out that was that now we're here
good job to him so us follows a family
of four they're on vacation they go to
the vacation cab and the wife the mother
is a group to starve the entire movies
played by Lupita Nyong'o and the husband
and father of the families played by
Winston Duke yes that is mbaku I love
that dude I love that he didn't get you
know let's just say and while they're at
their vacation cabin they basically get
terrorized by this other family by other
family I mean some evil version of their
family same actors played the good ones
and their evil opposites at first I was
like cause it's like a home invasion
movie at first and that's what I loved
about Jordan Peele the guy transcends
the horror movie genre a lot of people
critics reviewers fans myself included
watch a lot of modern-day horror movies
and were like ah it doesn't really have
it I'm looking for I hope someone brings
something new to the genre I'm just
saying we've seen it all cuz it's not
just horror its horror it's thriller I
would call this movies thrillers more
than horror
there are definitely horror movie
elements in it like a first I was like
home invasion movie then it goes on to
kind of feeling like a slasher movie
then it feels like a horror chase movie
this is the plot progresses it evolves
and it gets bigger and everyone did a
great job in it like Lupita Nyong'o we
know she's good we've seen it be great
so it's no surprise that she's great in
this movie just kind of it frustrates
you to see that other movies that have
her just kind of waste her come on Maz
Kanata you're wasting Lupita Nyong'o I'm
usually young actors that dislike well
are they gonna pull it off mmm and
that's without them having to play a
good version in a bad version of
themselves
what is everyone in this movie pulled it
off and I pulled off something that's
not easy to do and Winston Duke I
haven't seen a lot of movies with him in
it other than Black Panther but this is
totally a different role than Black
Panther he shows that he can just be a
normal family man is funny and by funny
I mean the Jordan Peele hits a good zone
here a lot of people are like I'm gonna
interject humor but doesn't always fly
with Jordan Peele most of the time he
hits a good zone where it doesn't
compromise the horror in general or at
least the thriller element couple of
times one in particular if anyone asks
me for an example this
senile bring up it was a scene where I'm
like you're being way too humorous way
too light-hearted for the tone they're
going for right now which is intense and
you're about to die why are you having
this conversation why are you having
this much too long
humorous conversation that's much too
long and much more humorous than it
should be for the situation really
Jordan Peele shows that he is the man
he's the new guys the new face of
thrillers in cinema he isn't know what
I'm saying here he's the new Shyamalan
like the early days of Shyamalan you
know when it was like oh my gosh an M
night Shyamalan movie he made a new
movie I'm gonna watch it like right now
that's Jordan Peele for this generation
in fact please don't compare us to get
out it would be like comparing
unbreakable to the sixth sense couple of
times in this movie I was like oh my god
that's hard to watch nothing anything
particularly violent was happening in
there but it was just it was intense
that's what Jordan Peele apparently
understands about thrillers and horror
movies is that it's not they're just for
gore you're telling a story about
characters in this case a family if you
want things to be thrilling and or
scariest not with blood you need the
audience to make them feel like they're
just in mortal danger and when he goes
for that he hits the bull's eye in the
end I really enjoyed us it had what I
was looking for for a movie like this
where I get out and I'm like I like the
Outer Limits I like The Twilight Zone
this reminded me of that and or black
mayor haven't seen black bear seen a
couple episodes of black mayor but every
time I compare a movie to the twilight
zone or the Outer Limits people in
comment section are like and black
mayors all right taking it on faith and
black mayor I walk out of us saying that
was a great time worth watching in
theaters and worth buying on blu-ray at
the very least taking your friend to
embittered you want to say pretty sweet
movies let's go definitely support this
movie if you like good movies and or if
you want to see the gargoyles movie that
he wants to do I mean it's worth
supporting without the option of
gargoyles but you know what I'm saying
right so us have you seen it why did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]